[Musique]
merci André Richard d'avoir accepté
notre invitation nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure vous
êtes élu du Barin apparenté au groupe
les républicains vice-président de la
commission des affaires européennes on
va commencer en parlant de l'info he de
ce début de journée c'est donc cette
trêve qui a pris fin entre Israël et le
Hamas et les combats qui ont
immédiatement repris dès 6h fin de la
trêve est-ce que vous êtes inquiè de la
situation on serait à moins on serait à
moins euh malheureusement la reprise des
combats traduit l'arrêt de libération
des otages c'est c'est c'était indiqué
comme ça on pouvait espérer
qu'effectivement çael puisse continuer
vous savez
que la la libération de hier
naturellement c'est une joie toute
libération de d'otage est une joie
quelle que soit d'ailleurs sa
nationalité il faut le dire hein mais il
en reste beaucoup malheureusement et la
reprise des combats à cet égard est tout
à fait tout à fait inquiétante ouais
alors évidemment quel que soit la
nationalité toute libération d'otage est
importante mais hier on a vu la
libération de cet otage
franco-israélienne miashem c'est la 4e
autage française euh libérée relâchée
par le Hamas la 5e même Emmanuel Macron
demain ser rend au Qatar un acteur clé
dans les négociations qu'est-ce que vous
attendez euh de cette de ce déplacement
du chef de
l'État on sait bien que le Qatar a joué
un rôle dans la libération de certains
otages à noté que le Qatar
euh à jouer d'autres rôles et je
m'arrêterai là notamment en aidant
puissamment le Hamas quand même bien
donc j'espère quand même que le chef de
l'État qui s'arrête au Qatar parce
qu'effectivement il est à DOA le
documentaire le disait pourra obtenir
d'un peu quelque chose de plus encore
pour la libération des otages mais
peut-être que au-delà de la libération
des otages euh le Qatar qui a quelques
moyens on le sait bien vis-à-vis du
Hamas pourra peut-être faire en sorte
que ce conflit s'arrête il faut bien que
ça s'arrête mais la France peut peser on
a vu la France elle a envoyé un navire
militaire hôpital elle a accueilli les
premiers blessée est-ce qu'elle est euh
réduite à faire de l'humanitaire
finalement ou est-ce qu'elle peut peser
vraiment sur le cours de ce conflit
écoutez je suis bien obligé de dire qu'à
l'heure actuelle elle pèse pas beaucoup
enfin clairement hein voilà
euh peut-elle peser plus
euh écoutez ça dépendra très très
clairement du comportement du président
de la République à cet égard et il faut
lui poser la question on suivra son son
déplacement ce sera demain on va parler
d'unutre sujet c'est la loi immigration
puisque les députés examinent en ce
moment même en séance dans une ambiance
parfois houleuse le texte en modifiant
la version du Sénat en détricotant
certains points que vous avez voté
notamment l'aide médicale d'État qui a
été rétabli un compromis a été trouvé
sur l'article 3 qui n'est ni la version
initiale ni la version du Sénat sur la
régularisation des travailleurs dans les
métiers en tension est-ce qu'avec ces
modifications vous pensez un accord cor
final possible c'est mal parti en tout
en tout état cause hein à partir du
moment où nous avions clairement dit
quelle était notre ligne rouge je parle
au Sénat et qu'on voit que c'est
détricoté comme vous le disiez à l'heure
actuelle à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
vraiment mal parti je je je souhaite
naturellement que on puisse infiner
trouver un accord mais d'après ce que
j'entends dire à l'Assemblée d'abord les
LR ne sont pas satisfaits le groupe LR à
l'Assemblée n pas satisfait en for sont
surtout divisé on a vu cette tribune
dimanche de 17 députés LR qui voulent
être constructif sur le texte qui n'est
pas la ligne officielle d'Éric suutier
et d'Olivier marlex vous comprenez ces
division alors avant de parler de
division je crois quand même savoir que
hier pour autant que je sache ils
étaient assez uni notamment sur
l'opposition à ce qui a été fait en ce
qui concerne les métiers en tenstion
donc il faut aussi relever ce qui marche
he bien euh alors je comprends ces
divisions vous savez qui c'est c'est je
crois qu'ils étaient 17 députés LR à à
dire que ils accompagnaient totalement
le Sénat dans dans dans dans le texte
tel qu'il était sorti de chez nous moi
je trouve ça plutôt sympathique de voir
que des des des
députés soutiennent un travail qui a été
fait ici je peux vous assurer que c'est
un travail particulièrement sérieux
c'est pas moi d'en parler c'est à au
président de la commission des lois un
travail vraiment sérieux qui a été fait
euh je comprends pas d'ailleurs pourquoi
il faut détricoter cet accord euh
lorsque j'entends sur l'aide médicale
d'État dire que mon dieu la France va
s'occuper désormais simplement ou
seulement des des
des immigrés irréguliers lorsqu'ils sont
proches de la mort j'ai lu ça hier mais
c'est du n'importe quoi que que l'on
regarde de façon précise ce qui a été
fait véritablement au niveau du Sénat et
on verra que c'est franchement frappé au
coin du bon sens je ne comprends pas
pourquoi au niveau de l'Assemblée
nationale il y a des oppositions à cet
égard et et et quels que soient les bans
concernés que ce so soit certains a qui
trouvent qu'on peut-être on a été trop
loin d'autres d'ailleurs trouvent que on
n pas été assez loin et et CEA donc
voilà bon nous on a essayé de faire le
job et d'essayer de faire en sorte que
on puisse trouver un accord je le répète
frapper au coin du bon sens et qui ait
des chances d'être repris par
l'Assemblée nationale dans les
meilleures conditions possibles moi ce
encore une fois ce ce ce ce ce
détricotage pour reprendre votre votre
terme je ne le comprends pas un mot sur
l'affaire de crpol et suite surtout de
cette affaire de crpol et de ce meurtre
du jeune Thomas ce lycéen de 16 ans
est-ce que on est dans l'illustration de
deux Frances aujourd'hui qui sont face à
face écoutez c'est pas nous qui avons
utilisé ce terme c'est c'est le défunt
ministre Colomb voilà qui l'a dit juste
avant de partir mais mais il faut bien
voir que la situation malheureusement ne
s'améliore pas clairement
alors alors là naturell
[Musique]
on relève plus particulièrement ce qui
s'est passé à Crépol l'ultra droite moi
je voudrais juste rappeler que lors des
émeutes on parlait on parlait d'ultra
gauche je sais pas quoi donc c'est vrai
qu'à l'heure actuelle il y a un
mécontentement de de d'une partie de la
population à l'égard d'ailleurs de
différentes décisions qu'ell soit ou
différents faits qu'il soit qu'il soit
d'un côté ou de l'autre de l'chiquier
politique
euh et et
ça franchement il faut il faut s'y
atteler il faudrait que que le Président
de la République puisqu'il veut
s'occuper de tout mais son son son ou
ses gouvernements là ils s'en occupe
assez pas pas comme il faut il s'occupe
de tout n'importe comment il est mais
mais non clairement
là c'est pas
simplement la faute de de du président
Emmanuel Macron c'est c'est une affaire
qui qui qui qui qui qui a pris de
l'ampleur ce cette ce que vous
appelez-vous cette opposition de entre
deux Frances c'est ça date pas d'hier
mais quand
même on pourrait faire en sorte que
plutôt que de mettre de l'huile sur le
feu on calme un petit
peu les uns et les autres et ça à
l'heure actuelle on peut pas dire que ce
soit franchement le cas on va parler de
l'actualité du Sénat puisque vous avez
auditionné hier le préfet de police de
Paris Laurent nun sur la sécurisation
des J et les restrictions annoncées de
circulation on va voir ce qui s'est
passé pendant cette audition avec qutin
calm qui nous
[Musique]
rejoint bonjour Quentin bonjour orien
bonjour André reart bonjour et Quentin
le préfet de police de Paris Laurent
nunz est donc venu s'expliquer hier
après-midi devant les sénateurs au
lendemain de l'annonce de la mise en
place pendant les jeux de paris d'un
système de QR code pour se déplacer dans
certaines zones de la capitale voilà
l'annonce avait été faite effectivement
dans dans Le Parisien mercredi matin le
préfet a expliqué que pendant les Joos
il faudra s'enregistrer sur une
plateforme numérique en fournissant des
justificatifs de déplacement avec un QR
code à présenter effectivement lors des
contrôles pour aller dans certaines
zones de la capitale l'audition d'hier a
été l'occasion d'une mise au point les
zones publiées dans la presse que l'on
voit on comprend qu'elles sont en fait
encore négociable tout comme les
systèmes de dérogation et ce que l'on
comprend également c'est que le préfet
en en fait il a préféré faire des
annonces en amont avec ses cartes pour
lancer le débat préparer aussi peut-être
l'opinion publique les Parisiens les
Franciliens sur ce qui va se passer le
joyeux bazar qu'on comprend qu' aura en
juillet et en août prochain dans la
capitale mais le système et bien il est
indispensable a bien dit Laurent NES
hier il a même été testé écoutez le
préfet de police de Paris devant les
sénateurs il y a eu le G7 à Biaritz en
2019 c'est ce qui a été fait c'est ce
qui a été é effit il y avait une
plateforme d'enregistrement pour les
riverins de manière à pouvoir justifier
de l'accès au périmètre de mémoire
d'ailleurs àarit ça concernait aussi les
piétons je rappelle que je ne parle que
de la circulation routière automobile
automobile voilà il nous paraissait plus
simple de prévoir une plateforme avec
justificatif papier QR code comme j'ai
pu le dire dans Le Parisien moi j'en
sais rien on va en discuter dans la
concertation on verra ce que veulent les
gens en général les gens préfèrent quand
même les QR codes parce que ça permet au
contrôle de flasher et les gens passent
on tout ça on en discutera plusieurs
sénateurs s'étaient étonnés de ces
annonces mercredi matin la mise en place
de cette collecte de données d'un
système informatique avec un QR code
tout ça ça rappelle la période covid et
donc ne manquait-il pas un projet de loi
un encadrement législatif pour des
mesures qui ressemblent à cell de l'état
d'urgence écoutez la réponse du préfet
de police de
Paris j'ai entendu donc des comparaisons
avec l'état d'urgence il faut une loi et
cetera bon tout tout le monde se
souvient que l'état d'urgence c'était
quand même des contraintes qui étaient
d'un autre niveau d'un autre niveau on
était sur des mesures où vous deviez
rester à votre domicile avec des des
contraintte pénal pénal moi la
contrainte qu'il y a à mes périmètre de
circulation c'est que vous rentrez Pasin
c'est c'est tout vous garez votre
voiture et vous rentrez à pied hein donc
avec des contraintes pénales une série
de mesures qui était beaucoup plus
restrictive il ne sagissait il ne
s'agissait pas de il ne s'agissait pas
évidemment euh de de de d'un simple unee
simple
restriction le fait de pénétrer en
véhicule dans une zone alors tout va se
jouer maintenant sur les concertations
qui sont en cours notamment sur ces
dérogations et ce système ce système de
QR code aussi pas mal on comprendre la
communicationin de ce qui s'annonce
comme un système compliqué voire même ça
a été dit hier une usine à gaz qu'est-ce
que vous en avez pensé vous monsieur
rechart est-ce que vous avez été rassuré
par l'audition
d'hier alors jeis d'AB abord dire que
l'émotion des collègues mercredi matin
était tout à fait légitime parce que
nous avons lu dans la
presse une utilisation de de QR code
pour des piétons même enfin on on s'est
dit mais qu'est-ce que c'est que ça quoi
et et et sans aucune information de la
part du Parlement enfin du Parlement
pardon de la part du gouvernement ça
c'était franchement inadmissible donc
nous avons profité de de de de cette
audition du du du préfet de police Nunes
pour pour avoir des informations
complémentaires et je dois dire que à
titre personnel j'ai plutôt été rassuré
aussi le sentiment que mes collègues
mais il faut leur poser la question le
l'ont été
également je je je je sais pas si si
tout ça a été bien perçu par par les les
téléspectateurs mais et en fait d'après
ce que l'on nous dit seuls les
interdictions de de circulation vont
véritablement gêner les les les riverins
de ces de ces différents sites ce sera
uniquement pour la cérémonie d'ouverture
où là va avoir beaucoup plus de contrôle
mais les zones dont on parlait qu'on a
vu dans Le Parisien c'est
essentiellement pour les voitures et les
moto alors les les piétons n'importe
comment pourront toujours accéder hein
on l'a dit clairement il y aura-t-il
préalablement un criblage des
populations concernées et cetera et
cetera à priori non d'après ce que nous
a dit le le le ministre le préfet de
police
je de ministre il était ministre bien
sûr euh mais allez global il faut bien
se dire qu'on ne peut pas organiser un
événement de ce type sans prendre un
minimum de de précaution c'est clair moi
je suis sénateur du du Barin comme vous
le
savez à Strasbourg au marché de Noël on
a naturellement ce type de de problème
régulièrement depuis des années qui
concerne naturellement
euh beaucoup beaucoup d'habitants ils
sont naturellement gênés par les mesures
qui sont prises autour du marché de Noël
qui d'ailleurs n'ont pas empêché vous le
savez bien un attentat de se produire
donc crainte pour cette année je faire
perdre pardon vous avez des craintes
pour cette année Mar no de strbour oh
pas plus que les autres années mais mais
c'est vrai que la situation se temps
hein on le sait bien donc ce qui se
passe au ce qui se passe à Gaza à
l'heure actuelle n'est pas pour
spécialement nous rassurer hein je l'ai
dit très clairement lisv en séance
mercredi matin avait dénoncé un
feuilletonnage extrêmement préoccupant
il avait aussi dit à ce momentlà avoir
saisi laacnil et le ministre de
l'intérieur ce qui peut choquer aussi
c'est qu'on apprenne ces mesures comm e
ça au fil de l'eau que ça pas été
davantage davantage encadré dès le
départ non alors je le répète le lire
dans la presse c'est juste pas normal
quoi alors le préfet de police s'est
engagé à revenir chez nous lorsque la
concertation AA avancé il nous dit
qu'effectivement il a mis ça dans la
presse il a fait une conférence de
presse pour ouvrir justement la
concertationou il avait peur que les
cartes fuitent et que ce soit mal
expliqué il a préféré prendre les devant
en fait voilà voilà mais il aurait dû
mettre le Parlement dans la boucle selon
soit mais je pense que à tout le moins
s'agissant de de de clairement de
mesures qui peuvent toucher aux libertés
publiques pas mettre le Parlement dans
la boucle au préalable c'est juste pas
normal enfin c'était ce que j'ai dit
tout à l'heure l'inquiétude l'émotion
d'un certain nombre de parlementaires
mercredi matin se justifie ouais il a
été question de la sécurisation des jeux
en Séan hier soir puisque on poursuit
l'examen du projet de loi de finance
depuis la semaine dernière et hier on
attaqué le volet sécurité 35000
policiers et gendarmes mobilisés pour
les j l'année prochaine un budget
sécurité estimé à 200 millions d'euros
qui n'a pas bougé depuis 6 mois est-ce
que les explications de la ministre en
séance elles vous ont rassuré sur l'état
de préparation des force de
sécurité très franchement pas plus que
ça on attendait d'ailleurs depuis un
certain temps des indications plus
précises sur la mobilisation de ces
forces de sécurité sur le coût de tout
cela et cetera donc les chiffres ont été
fournis hier soir mais brut de
décoffrage donc on sait pas très bien ce
qu'il y a
dedans bon bien j'appelle et nous
appelons tous de nos vœux la réussite
dans un contexte je le répète difficile
à l'heure actuelle de ces jeux olympique
et et paralympique
2024 à Paris mais euh il faudra trouver
le le moi je vais dire ça le bon
équilibre entre naturellement la
nécessité de faire en sorte que il ne se
passe rien de très grave enfin qu'il n
ait pas d'attentat là-bas et quand même
le le le la liberté individuelle des uns
et des autres alors c'est pas facile à
trouver euh il faut vraiment je répète
le bon équilibre des forces de police à
la hauteur bien sûr les moyens adéquats
mais d'un autre
côté faire en sorte que on n'empêche pas
les gens d'accéder que je je le répète
les habitants parce que notamment autour
de la cérémonie d'inauguration il y a
beaucoup beaucoup naturellement de de de
résidences d'AB an qui habite il faut
naturellement qu'ils puissent accéder
chez eux dans les conditions les
meilleures ça va être compliqué ça êre
compliqué il faut prendre naturellement
des contact avec avec les les hôtels qui
qui sont qui qui auront des réservations
il faut en s il faut faire en sorte que
tout ça se se passe bien c'est moi je je
répète le marché de Noël à à Strasbourg
ça fait maintenant des années qu'on fait
ce job que d'autres que moi d'ailleurs
font ce job et et on voit la difficulté
de trouver ce bon équilibre avec les
riverins également j'ai une dernière
question on on voit cette polémique qui
monte autour des Jos aussi dans un
contexte où on parle des transports
publics qui ne seraient pas prêts des
tarifs de ces transports et qui vont
doubler sur la période maintenant cette
polémique sur les QR codes est-ce que ça
fait un faisceau d'inquiétude ou est-ce
que vous dites que globalement les
signaux sont les bons oh c'est trop tôt
pour le dire hein vraiment trop tôt pour
le dire mais mais mais vous connaissez
quand même que ça fait une accumulation
principe on parlait hier en commission
des lois de principe de réalité cell et
ceux qui pensent on sait que ces Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques pourraient
se tenir en 2024 à Paris sans
contraintte sans rien euh maintenant se
rendre compte que ça ça s'organise
sérieusement quoi et donc il mais dans
les sondages on voit que les les
Français enfin voilà le le le le dis ils
ont des craintes sur plusieurs sujets où
ils n'ont pas confiance dans le fait
qu'on sera qu'on sera prêt voilà c'est
notamment la cérémonie d'ouverture qui
inquiète beaucoup euh ça ça il y a des
choses sur lesquelles les Français voilà
euh sont sont sont confiant et d'autres
où ils le sont ils le sont moins oui
mais encore une fois on est on est
encore à quelques mois il y a encore
plein de décisions à prendre j'ai vu
hier en posant la question au ministre
sur simplement sur le stationnement on
interdit la circulation des véhicules
dans un périmètre certes mais et les
voitures les voitures qui sont là est-ce
qu'elles peuvent se garer ou elles pe
elles ne se gareront pas je répète au
marché de Noël à Strasbourg depuis je
crois le le le le 22 novembre jusqu'à
fin décembre plus aucune voiture
stationnée dans les rues de de de de du
centrreeville enfin de de voilà de Lig
concerné sur Paris ça va donner quoi le
ministre a dit ah ben écoutez à ce
stadelà je sais pas encore vous répondre
c'est vrai il il y a encore des des
décisions à prendre et puis je allez je
vais quand même faire confiance à ceux
et celles qui sont en charge de ça pour
faire en sorte que ça se déroule bien
enfin voilà ne pleurons pas comme ça en
alscien on dit il faut surtout pas
dessiner le diable sur le mur voilà bien
moi j'ai pas envie j'ai pas envie de le
dessiner voilà d'c ok merci Quentin tout
à l'heure merci on va parler de ce qui
se passe en commission à l'Assemblée
nationale et ces députés qui détricotent
le projet de loi immigration voté au
Sénat le 14 novembre dernier on a
raconer tout ça dans le club ce sera
dans 20 minutes on va voir l'actualité
dans nos régions André Richard c'est le
principe de cette émission avec la
presse régionale on va ran dans la Loire
on retrouve Pierre Olivier verraau
bonjour merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
Pierre Olivier rédacteur en chef pour l'
hebbdomadaire régionale le pays on va
parler avec vous du prix du train et
notamment des trains du quotidien Pierre
Olivier
oui effectivement bonjour monsieur le
sénateur je je voulais vous interroger
sur une question relative au mobilité
nous sommes fait l'écho dans notre
édition paru hier de la proposition de
loi émise par le député LR de notre
territoire Antoine verorel marquez de
faire baisser le taux de TVA sur les TER
de 10 à 5 et5i % afin selon lui de de
favoriser
le des trains régionaux donc pensez-vous
qu'il soit opportun de faire entrer les
transports du quotidien dans les
produits et services de de première
nécessité pensez-vous simplement que
c'est une mesure qui puisse qui peut
favoriser le le développement des TER
dans nos
régions alors c'est sûr dès lors que ça
coûte moins
cher par définition ça peut amener plus
de gens à utiliser les les transports du
quotidien dont vous parlez alors pour
autant que je je je sache la proposition
de loi de ce de ce député ne concerne
que les TER c'est ça et pas et pas les
autres les bus et cetera ne sont ne
seraient pas concernés alors bon c'est
ma première observation
d'ailleurs pourquoi simplement sur les
TER franchement pourquoi simplement sur
les TR pourquoi pas bah je sais pas à
Paris sur le métro pourquoi pas sur les
les je répète les les les
bus qui qui là où il y a pas de TER il y
a des bus lorsqu'un TER arrive quelque
part il y a naturellement la personne
n'habite pas simple
dans cette gare là il peut habiter plus
loin donc il y a des bus et cetera les
bus de ramassage donc je je je je je
serai j'ai pas vu hein cette proposition
de détail j'en ai entendu parler
naturellement je moi si déjà on va là
autant pourquoi se limiter simplement à
une
TVA
réduite pour le seul t donc il faut
peut-être réfléchir à ça sur le fond
pour répondre à votre
question je suis pas sûr de vous à moi
qu'il faille
considérer des modes de déplacement de
ce type un ticket un ticket de TER comme
étant un moyen de première nécessité tel
que l'alimentation mais mais ind
dépendamment de
cela moi se pose très clairement une
question de coût ici on est en plein
marathon budgétaire
et on essaie de se limiter pour faire
sorte que on on on à tout le moins on
naggrafe pas la dette telle qu'elle est
à l'heure actuelle dans ce pays vous
savez qu'elle est supérieure à 3000
milliards d'euros
euh il est clair que s y a moins de TVA
il y aura moins de rentrée par
définition les rentrées servent à faire
tourner la machine à renouveler la
machine donc en terme de
d'investissement cet argent qui va
manquer on va le trouver où si c'est
simplement après pour charger encore
l'endettement public national où est
l'intérêt franchement donc à titre perso
je suis plutôt si c'est ce que vous
voulez savoir je suis plutôt réservé à
l'égard d'une proposition de ce type on
en a de vous à moi je répète on est en
marathon budgétaire aujourd'hui on en a
tous les matins de la part de nos
collègues qui disent bah voilà on
pourrait diminuer la TVA ici ici ici ici
et et nous enfin les LR en tant qui
essaye d'être de travailler en
responsabilité on est pas favorable à ça
merci Pierre Olivier merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous on regarde la une
du pays de votre hebdo la grande famille
des pompiers UER c'est à la une du pays
Ranis cette semaine merci beaucoup merci
Pierre Olivier d'avoir été avec nous on
va parler de l'Alsace pour terminer
puisqu'on parle des régions André
reichard vous êtes un fervant défenseur
de la sortie de l'Alsace du grand test
c'est exact et d'un retour à une région
Alsace pleine et entière Emmanuel Macron
il y a quelques semaines il a semblé
fermer la porte disant qu'il ne voulait
pas pas créer de nouvelles divisions du
coup est-ce que c'est pas une utopie du
moins jusqu'à la fin de ce quinquena ah
non pas du tout c'est pas une utopie
c'est une une
volonté de la population alsacienne
renouvelé d'année en année et je crois
on doit être au 4e auou 5e sondage à
intervales régulierers des
sondages notamment réalisés par par
quelqu'un que vous allez recevoir dans
deux instants monsieur Fourquet qui est
venu en Alsace qui connaît d'ailleurs
très bien le dossier et et 2/ers les
alaciens ça ça bouge pas ça bouge d'un
ou 2 % pas plus souhaite sortir du Grand
estest voilà donc vous avez compris que
pour nous c'est pas une illusion nous on
estce que l'État suivra est-ce que le
gouvernement suivra ah ben écoutez vous
voulez que je vous dise il aura pas le
choix il aura pas le choix clairement
dans la mesure où d'abord il a dit le
même président dont vous parlez tout à
l'heure a dit lorsqu'il était candidat
il est venu en aldas il a dit les
décisions doivent venir d'en bas doivent
venir d'en bas et pas toujours d'en haut
et ben chiche chez nous on est 2 tiers
en bas à a demandé cela il faudra bien
que quelque chose se passe et et notre
détermination elle est pleine et entière
je peux vous assurer la collectivité
européenne d'Alsace pour vous qui é un
premier pas pour vous ça suffit pas
est-ce que même si vous obtenez des
compétences supplémentaires c'est pas
suffisant alors ce sera de toute façon
pas suffisant à terme nous souhaitons
nous avions on demande pas grand-chose
nous avions une région Alsace qui
tournait bien qui était pionnière sur
plein de points on parlait des TER tout
à l'heure c'est chez nous que ça a
commencé et cetera mais je peux je suis
pas là spécialement pour faire un
cocorico simplement pour dire que ce que
nous avions marchait bien pourquoi on
nous l'a supprimé alors on essaie de
nous dire qu'à l'heure actuelle ça
marche mieux lorsqu'on est une grande
région moi ce que je sais en qualité de
d'homme politique maintenant depuis pas
mal d'années peut-être trop pour
certains
euh je sais que c'est dans la proximité
entre un élu et la population que ça se
passe c'est sûr et cette proximité elle
est de plus en plus demandée dans ce
pays à foursuie en Alsace et ben qu'on
tienne compte not naturellement de ce
besoin de proximité je suis persuadé que
si on retrouvait des des des régions à
taille humaine plus proche et et si on
retour j'ose le dire aussi si on
retrouvait le conseiller territorial
cher au président Sarkozi qui a été
supprimé par Monsieur Hollande
d'ailleurs un certain nombre collègues
socialistes me disent c'est pas
supprimer le conseil territorial c'est
pas ce qu'on a fait de mieux il
souhaiteraient le retrouver si on allait
de nouveau dans ce sens-l en Alsace on a
une collectivité européenne d'Alsace qui
est un départte
si on lui donnait les pouvoirs de la
région en même temps il y aurait les
mêmes qui s'occuperaient des compétences
départementales et régionales et je suis
sûr qu'on gagnerait en visibilité en
efficacité en compréhension en accueil
du public et cetera et cetera voilà vous
avez
compris on a compris votre position
merci beaucoup merci André Reard d'avoir
été avec nous dans 20 minutes dans le C
des territoires on ira chez vous au
marché de Noël de Strasbourg voir
notamment comment se passe ce marché qui
a ouvert vendredi et voir la tradition
du pain d'épice regardez comme c'est
beau ça c'est magnifique ce sera suive
tout à l'heure dans le club